[Musique]
les gens qui râlent comme pas possible
mais on apprend aux immigrants c'est pas
toi qui décide c'est moi
thirard mon allure on va faire le chemin
tranquille ou pour que l'udc est facile
avec son plateau de pas content d'être
avec moi mais c'est comme ça où tu vas
faire un petit peu de marche avec moi
[Musique]
aussi je suis fait chacun son
tempérament ne jugez pas les gens sur
les apparences moi je ne vous juge pas
sur les appareils non je vous aime bien
pourtant il ya rien qui pousse
vous avez dire ça comme ça la concerne
elle s on va passer donc à la question
suivante d'embûches et vous ne perdez
jamais parce que je lui ai promis que si
elle posait des questions trottent
retranché chez lui rendrait la monnaie
voilà bien jean-claude justement on va
continuer d'en discuter mon cher jean
claude s'est pas encore de prénom c'est
quoi bah c'est pas assez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors
poisson d'avril
ce n'est pas qu'il a chanté la
marseillaise c'est qu'il a il a vécu la
marseillaise ils étaient en transe il a
littéralement pris la bastille
[Musique]
là
ah ah
là quand les yeux flanche
c'est aussi le signe de cette campagne
c'est quand même lamentable de ce pont
du las c'est que mon macron a dit
clairement depuis le début qu'ils
voulaient pas débattre il voulait même
pas je crois à me rencontrer d'ailleurs
il a évité de même on se croise même pas
aujourd'hui mais c'est vrai que c'est
quand même dingue cette campagne a pas
de confrontation quoi et où on discute
pas vraiment un programme où on discute
pas vraiment politique était justement
de même que lui puisse rendre des
comptes sur ce qu'il a fait pendant cinq
ans moi j'assume totalement totalement
d'avoir constamment au nom de la france
parlé au président de la russie pour
éviter la paix pour éviter la guerre
pardonnez-moi
ensemble semble
liberté liberté et si
je ne verse pas les responsabilités de
vous devriez aussi en tirer aussi les
conséquences y compris mais en tire
toutes les conséquences de
7% un ordre social à 2% ou les panneaux
à une partie de la population et je
pense que c'était
même si longtemps rien moi j'ai jamais
insulté personne j'ai fait applaudir
vous savez hier j'ai fait de le dire par
l'ensemble de celles et ceux qui ont
voté pour moi au premier tour tous les
autres candidats ça sert à quoi
pardonnez moi c'est non après il ya des
est-ce que c'est pas un peu démago là où
ses pas mais vous pouvez pas de dire
tout et son contraire non je trouve que
vous avez pourquoi pas donc je suis je
trouve étonnant vous le fassiez le sud
une première
[Musique]
très conquérant chez trop parfois parce
que on a le sentiment que
tout m'a toujours réussi et parce que je
pouvais dans l'énergie très parfois trop
haut trop secouer les choses
et tout d'un coup il y en a un qui dit
tiens il ya loin du mali déjà
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai rappelé qu'à ce qui fait de perdre
ce pour ces derniers est quelqu'un dit
je crois que c'est de mes enfants mais
on ne veut lui donner un coup de main
qui aurait pu penser que kad merad se
retrouvent récité en 2022 lors d'un
débat entre les représentants des deux
finalistes de la présidentielle
attention pas le cas de miracle de baron
noir la série politique ça aurait pu
faire sens non voyez le un sketch de kad
merad c'est jean-michel à peu près la
cgc jean
michel comptable en excuser moi arrêter
les débats la prochaine fois
les 48 heures j'ai été contacté pour
venir vous rencontrer
malheureusement je ne rentrais pas dans
les 48 heures légales pour pouvoir
réserver un billet train malgré
l'urgence puisque ces mecs ont rencontré
le président était une urgence
visuellement pas eu accès au
sexe qui peut nous manque s'cusez moi ça
c'est
avec l approche du second tour vous
faisait du pied aux insoumis eau l air
aux jeux c'est les écolos jeunes écolos
mais hier j'ai découvert que vous
faisiez aussi vous tentiez de séduire
les femmes de bhl et de demis roussos
[Rires]
on a malgré tout contrairement aux
chiffres que vous pouvez donner baisser
le chômage il est passé de 9,6 à 7 4% et
le bureau international du travail comme
son nom l'indiqué l'organisme qui fait
référence il vous plaît peut-être pas
mais personne ne compte les catégories b
et c du chômage puisque ce sont des
actifs partiel est ce qu on apprend mais
madame non on les compte pas dans les
chiffres du chômage ne fait pas ils
seront contentes avec pas gérard majax
ce soir madame le pen cherche des jets
de l'arrêté arrêter ça bonjour gérard
majax bonjour mr jour en direct dans
télématin ça vous fait quoi de vous
retrouver comme ça dans le débat d'entre
deux tour entre marine le pen et
maillots de maquereaux moi je trouve ça
normal c'est les deux fois où on
m'appelle pas ou
n'est pas normal ça vous fait rire même
politique est un illusionniste aussi
fait apparaître du cheval être des
choses donc c'est normal de se parler un
petit peu avant le vote
mais c'est bien lui c'est la présidence
et bada
extraordinaire il est évidemment
accompagné de la première dame danielle
maquereau ou quoi la chaudière de
l'elysée comme la surnommait à l'elysée
justement
entouré d'enfants vous aviez voté au
premier tour quand même j'ai voté au
premier tour tan hidalgo c'est ça ouais
non alors nous alors pas du tout non non
non j'ai pas voté pour pour ma mère j'ai
voté pour jean luc mélenchon mais pas
par gross conviction en réalité c'était
pas parce que je trouvais que ce qu'il
disait était géniale particulièrement
mais son idée de faire une sixième
république je me suis dit que ça pouvait
être un moyen pour que les gens se
posent des questions sur le système dans
sa globalité
si vous n'arrivez pas convaincre déjà
vous propose enfants
non mais sur ce votre propre candidature
j'ai de la chance mes enfants toujours
voté pour moi mais après sur d'autres
élections débat
l2 ah oui vie n 2
elle a appris l'anglais en vitesse